[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort
lestrange death eaters and horcruxes
let's kick things off with a brief intro
on horcraxes a horcrux is created when a
wizard takes an object and binds a piece
of their soul to it the purpose is
immortality with the logic going that as
long as a piece of your soul survives
within the object then you can never
truly die its magic so dark so heinous
that it was kept a secret from most of
the wizarding world
yet despite many trying there are only
two known wizards to have discovered how
to perform it an ancient greek dark
wizard called herpo the fowl who created
one horcrux and voldemort who mastered
the spell and created seven but what
i've always wondered is why didn't the
death eaters follow in voldemort's
footsteps and create horcruxes
themselves surely voldemort would have
entrusted someone like bellatrix with
the knowledge of how to create one
wouldn't he
dumbledore once described tom middle
school gang as a mixture of the weak
seeking protection the ambitious seeking
glory and the thugish seeking a leader
who could show the more refined cruelty
it was these same students that are
considered to be the forerunners to what
would become the death eaters that we
see later on in the books and films
death eaters are pure blood radical
supremacists that cast unforgivable
curses without remorse and torture
muggles half bloods and blood traitors
alike death eaters murder people
willy-nilly so it's not unreasonable to
expect that they would be willing to
murder to achieve immortality
furthermore the death eaters were
hell-bent on maintaining pure magical
bloodlines in the wizarding community
and one very effective way of doing that
would be to remain immortal as a
pureblood
so is it just that the death eaters were
left in the dark by voldemort unaware of
what it was that he had achieved or was
it that the creation of a horcrux was
just too imposing after all horcrux
creation was even too dark to be
properly mentioned in a book about the
dark arts the following quote from
voldemort suggests that at least some of
the death eaters knew something about
what he had done and then i asked myself
but how could they have believed i would
not rise again
they who knew the steps i took long ago
to guard myself against mortal death he
says it right there who knew the steps i
took surely this suggests that he'd
educated them on poor cruxes right
now the book never explicitly states
which death eaters knew but i'm sure he
didn't mention it to all of them and
there's one in particular that comes to
mind when i think of who he might have
told bellatrix lestrange and who better
to create one than bellatrix with the
know-how and the bloodthirsty capability
why wouldn't she make one bellatrix
lestrange was one of the most feared
witches in a wizarding world her
fear-inspiring name and bloodthirsty
reputation were well deserved and she
was known to have murdered and tortured
many many witches and wizards her
magical capabilities were more than
impressive and she was widely considered
to be one of the most powerful and
dangerous witches of her time she was a
frightening pureblood that came from the
black family a long line of powerful
witches and wizards with a twisted
agenda more importantly however
belichick's estranged was lord
voldemort's most loyal follower but to
add to that she certainly wasn't just a
follower we have to address the elephant
in the room here because i think it
helps to answer this question bellatrix
was obsessed with voldemort though she
served him unquestionably she always
wanted more she wanted to be his queen
and she wanted to rule over the magical
and muggle worlds alongside him so what
better way to ensure that they could
rule together forever than by making
herself immortal as well in an interview
jk rowling discusses the intensity of
bellatrix's infatuation with her master
and bellatrix was as i think is clear
you know i doubt that people will be
particularly shocked to hear because i'm
sure they've deduced that bellatrix is
madly romantically in love with
voldemort this is you know that's the
obsession of her life and whether you
want to accept it as canon or not we
know from the cursed child that
voldemort and bellatrix eventually
conceive a child delfini delfini's
conception occurred sometime in the mid
to late 1990s in secret at the malfoy
manor this meant that her birth
coincided with the events of the
original books we just never had any
vindication of it her birth was kept a
secret by her parents because they
feared that their infamous reputations
would place her in danger especially in
the event of their deaths how and why
bellatrix and voldemort would go on to
conceive a child is unknown though i
suspect that it was more of a functional
conception a way of voldemort carrying
on the bloodline of his ancestor salazar
sutherin this fact only strengthened the
tie between voldemort and bellatrix
further which makes the question even
more potent why didn't bellatrix create
a horcrux here's what i think i think
that voldemort told some of his key
followers about horcruxes but i don't
think that he ever delved too much into
these specifics and i think that the
reason that he never delved into these
specifics wasn't to hide the process
from them but because he didn't believe
that they were strong enough to go
through with it creating a horcrux is
purportedly one of the most difficult
extreme and unknown magical processes
known in the wisdom world if it was hard
going even for someone like voldemort
one of the most innately powerful
wizards of all time then how can we
reasonably expect that death eaters
would be successful i just don't think
that he had the faith in them to go
through with at all why would he
encourage and risk losing his followers
to a process that he knew they wouldn't
be able to handle jk rowling described
the process of creating horcruxes as
dangerous and highly inadvisable yeah
but i would imagine that other people
you know other people are going to have
tried i think it would be naive not to
think that people have been trying for a
long time and thought they succeeded and
hadn't or else or else you know made
themselves or killed themselves in the
attempt it's such a dangerous thing to
do to add to this voldemort though
incapable of love did care for bellatrix
why would he risk her life his genuine
concern for her life is depicted in the
following passage which describes
bellatrix's death bellatrix's gloating
smile froze her eyes seemed to bulge for
the tiniest space of time she knew what
had happened and then she toppled and
the watching crowd roared and voldemort
screamed harry felt as though he turned
in slow motion he saw mcgonagall
kingsley and slughorn blasted backward
flailing and writhing through the air as
voldemort's fury at the fall of his last
best lieutenant exploded with the force
of a bomb
voldemort raised his wand and directed
it at molly weasley and no he wasn't
just angry because he lost another one
of his soldiers he was genuinely upset
that bellatrix was gone in fact i think
that voldemort may have even avoided the
topic of horcruxes specifically around
bellatrix so that she wouldn't get any
funny ideas to create one voldemort
likely knew of bellatrix's obsession
with him and he also knew that if he
planted the idea of her immortality in
her head she would have done anything in
order to achieve it had voldemort and
the death eaters won the wasting war and
had bellatrix survived i think that
maybe just maybe further down the line
voldemort would have introduced the idea
of her creating one in a controlled
environment in this way they would be
able to take their time and be extra
careful as to minimize any kind of risk
anyway i think that about sums it up did
you guys ever wonder this does my logic
make sense here if you enjoyed the
content please like the video subscribe
to the channel and leave a comment down
below
until next time remember it is our
choices that show what we truly are far
more than our abilities